perhaps famously steve had a bit of a
temper
steve jobs
would would you say his
particular personality in this aspect
was constructive or
destructive
in the process of
shaping these opinion-based
ideas
so in
build i write a chapter called [ __ ]
yes
and you lay out beautifully
the types of [ __ ]
and uh maybe you could speak to
the constructive and the destructive
types of [ __ ] okay
so there's really two delineations that
i
that i've found of you know real
fundamental ones and that is
again the why
why do i feel this person is an [ __ ]
okay they might not be
i feel this is a person who's an [ __ ]
are they motivated by their ego
or are they motivated by their mission
something they're trying to do that's
and doing in service of something else
right
sometimes those lines can be blurry but
it's usually pretty clear
when it's when it's ego motivated
you're it's clear they're just trying to
get up in the ranks push people down
shove people aside i think we saw a
president do that on a stage once
um
you know i'm me and i'm the you know i'm
the
the
the guy right and i'm going to prove it
by pushing everyone away and being
nefarious or what have you either
passively aggressive or aggressively
aggressive
but they're doing about themselves
there's another one which is someone
who's so attentive to detail and
unrelenting
that they're trying to get the right
things for the customer or the in
service of their mission and they want
to make sure we fulfill those things
right
and they really care they don't
micromanage all the details but they
micromanage the details where the
customer it touches the customer in some
way
people who work with those types of
people who are unrelenting and push you
and might make you upset a lot of times
it's a knee-jerk reaction to go they are
an [ __ ]
get off my back you're an ah
right and you're protecting your ego
because what's happening is that person
is usually pushing you beyond your
boundaries
they see something
that we can do or you can do
that you're just either
not wanting to do for whatever reason
you're not confident in that
you you're like i don't want to take the
extra time and say no we need to get
that done and pushing you
okay
and so
when
we came to those areas it wasn't just a
one-on-one it could be steve against the
team going we need glass instead of
plastic on the front face of the iphone
and we're going to do this
and we're like god
you know and so we did it
and he pushed us because he didn't know
all the details but he could see in our
minds that we're like
yeah we could probably yeah we could
probably but man it's really putting us
in risk and we we laid out the risks for
him and he's like i'm willing to take
those risks we'll do that we're like we
might be three months late he's like
this is so important we need to stay on
time
you know but it would be all the time
push push push i re it reminds me of
like kids growing up and me as growing
up you know when your parents push you
to make you grow beyond your boundaries
your personal boundaries and you're like
god damn it i'm sorry
you know but they do it for the right
reasons now let's see it's not bullying
it's not about bullying it's not about
demeaning
it's about either pushing you to another
part of the mission that needs to get
done or it's about critiquing your work
but not judging you yes well there's a
lot to say there so one
uh it's fascinating it really is
fascinating and you laid out a very nice
picture but it's
it does feel like there's sometimes gray
areas which is why it makes all this
very complicated so one question i have
for you in terms of glass
on the iphone
um
how important is it that
like steven that case
is right
because
i could argue
each side it seems like in one sense
just having a strong vision and opinion
is already going to make everybody grow
even if it turns out to be the wrong as
long as you are sort of standing your
ground um
you know napoleon invading russia or
something in the winter
like it's just not gonna be he's not
that good right this is not a good idea
but i'm gonna hold
do that and then once you decide you go
all in
and then from that even if the whole
team knows it's the wrong decision just
sticking by it powering through you will
learn through the pain of it like
everybody will learn so that's one side
the other is maybe
um the [ __ ] the vision driven [ __ ]
uh gets to be
more and more of an [ __ ] if they have
a track record
of
through that process having built people
up having made the correct decisions
they can't they're not allowed to be an
[ __ ] they're in rare air and no one
can challenge them right right
steve was never that that's the great
thing he was he was never
unchallengeable you could challenge him
now let's
now this the the plastic to glass story
is a perfect example of this
so at the beginning of the project well
before we were going we had always had
these things about you know plastic
front ipods these kinds of things these
scratches and all that stuff
so we said are we going to have a glass
or a plastic disp
a cover for the display because the
display was glass underneath it
we argued back and forth about glass
versus plastic and then we all landed
together on plastic
okay the original decision was plastic
and the reasons were okay we don't want
to make a mistake glass can break
you know uh
people drop them all the time
so we don't want to have a fragile
device
because you're going to be using even
more than a music player right
and you're going to be holding your head
and putting in your pocket and misses
and all that stuff
so we went down the road with plastic
when it was shown when the product was
shown at mac world
in 2007 the first time that was plastic
we had just enough of them in the field
at the time we started to start seeing
light scratches on the
plastic
reviewers who didn't have the device yet
because it was behind glass if you if if
you remember 2007 the jesus phone comes
up and no one could even touch them you
could just look at it in this beautiful
museum quality box like it came from the
future or whatever the past it was like
oh and you just looked and that was all
you got but then people said well what
screen is what covers on that you know
reviewers who knew better you know and
they're like uh it's plastic and they
were like really
and so there was enough of a doubt there
and then when we started to do it and
then steve changed the frame of
reference of the question or or of the
result of what the customer would think
and he was like
if we designed it with plastic
and it's in their pocket all the time
and it gets scratched by coins lightly
scratched or by keys or something like
that
that is a design problem
we need to fix the that was our bad
if they go off and drop it
or even slightly drop it
and it cracks
it's the customer's fault and they have
much lower they have less likelihood to
complain yes they'll complain but
they're part of that
of that failure
yes oh that's fascinating and then
there's truth to that right
because then they were part of why it
failed whereas the design they didn't do
anything wrong was just sitting in their
pocket and it's you know scratching
and that's normal use
abnormal use has been dropping we're
like
oh
now we get it and so we all moved to
that mindset when you framed the problem
and the solution in that way versus the
original framing where we all landed on
plastic so
and then he was unrelenting on that but
we all had moved
and we have moved mindset and we
understood the why and we marshaled
together
and then by the end of june and it was
crazy the mechanical product design
teams
sourcing
all of us all the the partner corning
pulled together to make that happen
because it was the right reason right so
this
you know you look at these stories and
you hear just the top line
rumors of the takeaways but that's not
usually how it all happened of like one
leader was
that's not how steve was now i've seen
leaders who were just
pounding you know and just had no
real empathy for the team and
understanding the why and it's just it
is the way i want it right i am the
supreme leader
that wasn't like that
when he just had a very strong opinion a
very strong opinion but it was
challengeable uh it was challengeable
and if you came with the right thing you
know it was you could you could modulate
that but you had to come with a team it
couldn't just be you you had to become a
team and data and to overcome because it
was a very strong opinion and there's
personal quirks of character like you
said
days and good days bad days and good so
there's also the three options you said
you you notice that the third option is
always going to be the one that's picked
uh sure those kinds of idiosyncrasies
idiosyncrasies and that so that brings
up another thing okay
uh
you said challenge the idea not the
person
you know
i'm somebody who has a you know i have a
temper i've used colorful language and
so on when on teams i work in my private
life i'm much calmer and so on but i get
when i get really passionate with
engineering teams
and i've been called an [ __ ]
i mean i am distinctly aware that you
cross lines uh often
um
there's like levels right sure
you know you could it has to do with
language and how language is heard so
for example you could say a lot of stuff
to me you could swear you could say
stuff that sounds purse like
uh
like i don't know
lex
sometimes i think you're the dumbest
human on the face of the earth or
something i don't know
this sounds very personal right but i'm
not going to take that personally i
understand what's being said and then
i'm also noticed that there's other
people that take stuff more personally
this has to do with teams and figuring
out like okay who's going to take
certain words personally and not and you
have to know that's what takes makes a
great coach a great leader a mentor you
have to you have to like
factor all that in but it just there's
something about just being an [ __ ]
and um
being passionate and really driven
that sometimes you do cross lines
and that's
i don't know what to do with that
because it feels like it comes with the
territory like you have
it seems like
you can't just have a perfectly
optimized
no
no absolutely not we're humans yeah
we're humans we don't have a pro
everyone's programmed the same way to
react the same way to given stimulus
right yeah so
you know you said i don't know if this
was a real example but you said oh
you're the dumbest human on earth or
whatever i would never say that
absolutely never and if someone said
that to me or i saw someone else say
that to another person on the team
absolutely not that is not allowed
because that's judging someone you may
be heated and you can get heated and you
can say it in your intonation but to
then
try to put a label on it and put a label
on a person that is not allowed so if
you let that kind of culture happen and
it becomes somewhat
you know sometimes it's ingest
you know it has to be very much ingested
and those two people have to have a
really good working relationship so but
but other than that i'm sorry it's gonna
be a lot
more you could say a septic in that way
that you're not going to add that stuff
in but you can do it with all other
types of ways without saying that
because then people who do react to that
kind of language
and don't have those shields because
they don't might not might not have that
stream confidence level that you do and
you can just brush it off you can that
can be very
cancerous in a team because people then
mean that and then they see oh that's
the right way to be you got to snuff
that out and you got to be that you got
to be that change or that model that you
want to show the team
yes it's too even if it doesn't affect
me it's going to affect a a significant
enough fraction of
brilliant people where that shouldn't be
part of the culture exactly and and and
other people see that happen and then oh
i guess that's acceptable right just
like politics in the workplace is that's
acceptable or not i call it out exactly
when i see it in front of everyone right
because
it's just another ego driven thing you
have to set the tone
as a leader for what you want your
organization to be and how to it gets
reflected in the world and you have to
uphold that and you can sure you can
have an excursion outside of that but
you have to go back and say i'm sorry
yeah
yeah you have to go and apologize heal
and said i was not the person i wanted
to be that day i'm really sorry
yeah this is and even in front of the
team
and have that humility and say we're all
human here and just because i'm the
leader doesn't mean i don't make
mistakes so have the self-awareness
apologize exactly
and that that's that's also part of the
culture
um oh yeah how are you different from
steve as a leader and designer so you
you've spoken about sort of what made
you stronger which is he was able to
challenge he was able to push you to
bring out the best
well i come from the technical angle
right
deep technology software hardware
systems thinking you know implementation
all that stuff so i so i have a
different ben he
wanted to be an engineer started but
really he was much better at all the
other things the storytelling the
interfacing and and being the voice of
the customer and being that product
marketer in a way right that we talked
about i grew into being the product
marketing and marketing he came really
the other way right and never got really
deep technically so that's two different
mindsets no one's not better or worse
it's just that's how it is and it takes
all kinds to to
and and all kinds can do great designs
did it manifest itself differently just
the fact that you came from those diff
uh different places absolutely
like what uh
so like the discussion about glass on
the iphone was probably had a different
flavor to it sure when you started
getting into the technical details
enough so you're getting the third order
technical details and he can't argue
with that anymore
he's like okay
you know at some point he's like i can't
win this war like
the and he learned that very early on
because he didn't like the way
the look of the macintosh
um board the pcb was laid out
he wanted to be beautiful on the outside
and on the inside he's like why are all
these wires running this way why doesn't
it have all this symmetry and we have to
make it beautiful on the inside and and
the even the traces on the boards have
to look a certain way so the teams made
the board they knew that would work and
then they made the board that the way
steve wanted it and that didn't work and
then steve instantly figured out like at
some point don't micromanage every
single detail there's some things he
doesn't know enough about so he would
get out of that but that was one of
those instances where he pushed really
hard and that's his opinion so they said
okay we're going to make it a
data-driven decision we're going to make
both i'm going to show you the results
right and then from there he didn't get
into those details so from that you
could have a great challenge right
because then you could get those data
and say we can't do that and let me show
you why or we can do that and then steve
would go you can't do that and you're
like oh we can do that let me show you
right so there's certain times when you
were like bringing something to reality
that he didn't think could exist
right so
it was that it was always that creative
tension that interaction that was so
successful right
i think but there was one other
fundamental thing that was different
and that it graded on the team
and that i made sure and i learned from
to not do
and and i over maybe overdue now in the
opposite direction which is
when there's a great idea that comes
from the team
acknowledge that person and go that is a
great idea as the leader you know the
opinion driven that's a great idea let's
build on that let's see if that can do
that or it's a great idea but not for
now put it aside but call out when
people have great ideas because it's
infectious and that means not ideas that
come bubble up to the customer level but
inside the organization people like they
get rewarded for their ideas and say
that's a great one
steve was always like
you give an idea
and he would go hmm okay
i don't know
the next day 24 hours later it would
come back with slight modifications i've
had this genius idea
right and it's sooner or later we'd we'd
look around the table and we'd like roll
our eyes and go here we go again so it
demotivates you from generating ideas a
little bit yeah well you know we got
used to it but you know later on in the
team yeah you know it was just not
it it just it doesn't want to bring the
best right because if you're always like
ah
the reaction is never that's a genius
idea
it was always like it was either
negative or
neutral right yeah then it doesn't it
doesn't have that same emotional effect
that you want you to bring your best
yeah sometimes it's fun when people get
excited about it just yeah yeah yeah you
kind of build on top excitement it could
be but coupled with sort of harshness
when the idea is bad and you call out
the bad ideas too so it's the good and
the bad
oh you could say
you don't you don't have to say bad
ideas like maybe not now let's table
that for later let's discuss it or say
that's a decent idea but did you think
about that idea this way not just no or
yes but let's talk about why that might
not be applicable in this case so that
they can learn so the next time they
bring the next idea they can modulate
and understand and start seeing through
the opinion based decision makers or the
databases to bring it and bring better
formatted arguments or ideas so that you
have better chance of success the next
time yeah right you got to train through
those moments you got to teach those our
teaching moments
yeah
i aspire to be that kind of person i'll
i'll usually say that that that idea is
[ __ ]
that is the like the like and then you
that i remember that that this brilliant
person just gave that really shitty idea
so i remember to make sure the next time
they give a good idea really compliment
that good idea but i personally
i mean it's emotion but i i call out the
really shitty ideas but you should call
it the really great ones yeah if you let
the pendulum swing both ways then
everybody goes he's balanced yeah it's
always one way
why bring any idea i'm all about the
pendulum right
you got to have both
the joy and the pain
don't just give me pain
you